[Music]
um let's see here i i'm trying to find
okay here it is this is an old news
article an old news video now this video
has probably
got it
who went to school it's probably got to
be
at least 10 to 15 years old okay i don't
know exactly when but i want i don't
care how so there's an old article a
video i know a bunch of people have seen
it but i did it until yesterday
and i wanted to share this with marsh
blackfaced as you see there to give a
speech on martin luther king jr the
colorado second grader dressed up as the
civil rights leader complete with black
isn't this like an old one i feel like
i've seen this story it's very old it is
okay i'm saying it's very old oh okay
back pain on his face is part of a class
history project but the costume didn't
go over well his painted face i just
wanted to show the stark difference
between
how when this happens versus ten years
ago versus how it would happen now okay
just this is great offended some
students and a teacher and he was sent
home after refusing to wash it off
they thought it was inappropriate and it
will be disrespectful to black people
but i say that it's not i like black
people
no he likes my name no then the name the
name the name
what was the name
i didn't see it
the name
what was the name
attention this afternoon an
eight-year-old blackfaced as you see
there to give a speech on martin luther
king jr the colorado second grader
dressed up as the civil rights leader
black paint on his face as part of a
class history project but the costume
didn't go over well his painted face
offended some students and a teacher and
he was sent home after refusing to wash
it off
they thought it was inappropriate and it
will be disrespectful to black people
what's the matter
royce
what's the matter
what's the matter
his name is sean king
he's always wanted to be black i've
never seen this he's always wanted to be
black
marsh i watched this today on day wave
because that's that's how it came up and
i
asked frozen we missed this completely
right i i did i until i
watched this right now i
i saw it right it's the first thing i
saw
i mean they only put his name there for
like a millisecond so it's weird
but i absolutely
like
immediately it was the first thing i saw
oh my god dude
trump broke something right
this is hilarious like
something happened in 2016
that like
pushed us into a different timeline
right and it's just like
something happened
everything's broken this is amazing holy
[ __ ]
but i say that it's not i like black
people
sean king said that we know
i don't want to be mean to them it's
just a costume i don't want to insult
anybody
a school district spokesperson can i ask
you a question
because this is just occurring to me now
sure
there's no way a news crew
went over to that school immediately
when this incident happened and they're
telling the story in past tense
did they make this kid
dress back up in blackface to interview
him
right oh my god i didn't even think of
that that makes sense
they probably made him dress up in
blackface again there's no way they just
went right to the school oh my god we
gotta get a van there and interview this
kid right away so they said could you
put the costume back on
which means that they asked the kid to
put blackface on a second time
oh this video gets better marsh when i
tell you
it's the greatest video of all time oh
no no you haven't even got it to the
best part yet you're right that's great
but it gets better frozen knows why
comment on the face paint in terms of
race relations only saying that it
violates the school's dress code but his
parents and some other adults are
outraged saying this was not an act of
racism the boy was just trying to get
into character
what is your take on this was it wrong
for the boy to wear black face paint for
that school project do you feel it was
racially insensitive we are excited to
be joined today by d snyder lee
what
what what is going on
because you figure when you have a black
face what is happening
see you figure when you have a black
this is not the onion by the way i need
to point that out you figure you have a
blackface controversy the person you
need to have on is
d snyder i
clearly by the way
clearly a guy that was booked six months
ago
could d snyder clearly booked some
morning uh show appearance like a month
or two in advance because he probably
had a show in town
and this just happened to be the topic
and they're like well we also got d
snyder so
just stick him in on the blackface panel
so dee where are you going to be playing
tonight
what if i told you i'll be at the uh
hammerstein ballroom uh tonight tickets
on sale it gets even more wild so look
at this panel of people why is this
happening look at this panel of people
you might think that you know the
opinions of all these people but you
don't lead singer of twisted sister
thanks for being here the second grader
second grade is this malicious or is it
perhaps ignorant on his parents part so
you turn to me because i used to wear a
full face of makeup okay i got it um
by the way um
leading me has uh photographic evidence
of this makeup incident show links
okay
let's see okay that's not okay this is
what okay
you can't
wow how controversial
man d snyder wow yeah it based d
snyder's [ __ ] base
so quickly to me jesus christ
i could hear the kid talking a little
bit he seems to be sincere but i don't
have a racist bone in my body but i
wouldn't put black face on because it's
just not acceptable and his parents
should know that and a black person
putting white face on that's not
acceptable either
like michael jackson uh white girls sami
sos the white girls
so his parents should know better and if
the kid doesn't it's up to the parents
to do the right thing so maybe this
opened up an important dialogue then in
the community and about that
well i mean how many other schools you
think are dealing with this kids coming
to school with blackface on it and it
was a terrible costume that's another
thing i mean it didn't even look good
that charlie chaplin mustache he's got
going on there i thought he was a whole
nother character well you know we
certainly know blackface invokes so much
pain um on it's no pain there's no pain
being invoked let's relax on
african-americans and us in the
african-american community but i will
say that uh we really should get his
parents both fired from their jobs and
have this kid thrown out of school
you know what
no watch this you've got to get the kids
no i was kidding i know they're not
going to say this because it's so long
ago but that's nowadays that's what
you'd say watch what the black reporter
says african-american community but you
got to give the kid credit dr martin
luther king civil rights activist leader
he's you know he was trying to do the
speech i get that i get that but i but
but he's second grade i mean do
i'm wondering if we're being overly
sensitive
right
i mean this was 10 years ago
can we go back
right last question yes she passed the
test well now hold on let her finish
because she says something else before
we ask okay remember the other thing
she's about to say as adults by saying
you know was this kid really stepping
over the line here
well another thing was it the kids idea
to do it or
you know or did the parents come up with
the idea to do it he wrote a report on
martin luther king i wrote a report on
martin luther king i didn't do it in
blackface i i said the n word a lot yeah
i mean a lot i'm never bored
it was a lot
yeah he's in second grade i know we've
uh we live in a overly pc society you
have no idea what's coming d
but i just think the parents are just a
sweet summer child i have no idea that
okay we understand what you want to do
son i think maybe there's a better way
to do this i just i wonder if he if that
was his idea that's literally what dee
snyder
just said yeah but i was like wondering
whose idea was but he just said that
like where does he get his ideas just
seems like something more of the parent
it seems a little adulty second second
grader putting on black face yeah
doesn't seem like aha if nothing else
it's certainly opening the dialogue and
maybe getting some folks to think twice
amanda now these are people these are
normal people sitting in their comments
back then she writes ridiculous this
little boy did this out of respect not
hate he wanted to be just like mlk
there's nothing wrong with that in my
opinion ricky lewis says stop making
something out of nothing
amanda hurtado says he is just a kid
learning in the way children enjoy how
to learn how to imagine how did we get
here
i don't know how did we get here so fast
like so how fast
he didn't know what he was doing was
considered wrong decades ago and fritz
lee says we've lost like 20 000 feet of
altitude in our society
in the course of about 10 seconds
you know what i mean like that's the
equivalent of what's happened
ones who face discrimination
not a bunch of white people in arizona
or colorado for that matter it is easy
for a white person to write time to quit
playing the race card because she is not
suffering and she has never suffered
from racism now watch what the black
girl says to that from the south and
that certainly was a big part of of my
culture confederate flags and such but
again i think the sensitivity here just
has to be that we need to step back and
wonder he's a second grader and i don't
know for being overly sensitive i'm
waiting for this black chick to say
heritage not hate
um
so now does she pass the verse test
knowing everything you know about her
mindset
well not now she's probably there let's
just say now yeah jesus christ
bro sorry miami milf he didn't even mean
to make fun of you did you see that one
ill probably 50. yeah you're a little
old for me i'm sorry
what do you want
miami milf isn't old she's biblical
that's the question and we debated this
a long time in the newsroom today
sean is adamantly opposed to this young
man doing this and it's glad that the
school as well stepped in
all right all right well next on abc 15
now earlier this okay so anyway
that was a
really crazy right it was a wild ride
isn't it crazy to see how that went like
i know this is old i know a bunch of
people have seen this i'm sure it's kind
of weird though because it was uploaded
may 18 2012 and it only has 16 000 views
so that's not a lot right
had any other people seen this i'm sure
i feel like this had to be huge right